اجتياح رابع لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لمخيم نور شمس في طول كرم شمال الضفه
الغربيه خلال اسبوعين قوات الاحتلال
استهدفت ما تبقى من بنى تحتيه في المخيم
وخربت كافه ملامح الحياه فيه ولا شعب في
العالم مستحيل ذاك ذاك الشعب الفلسطيني
وبعده بذو والحمد لله صامدين هذا بتغم
تزبط الاقتحامات باتت خبزا شبه يومي ابناء
الضفه واستهدف القصف بمسيرات الاحتلال
مخبز المخيم لا يعجنون هنا فتحين الصباح
امتزج باثار الخراب لكن مخزون الصمود لم
ينضب
بعد هو الاستهداف مش بس فقط لمخبز يا
صديقي الاستهداف لكل فئات الشعب الفلسطيني
لكل المخيمات ان كان صغير او كبير يعني
الجيش مش فارقه معه اي مبادي او اي اخلاق
ان كان ولد صغير او كبير الحمد لله رب
العالمين في
النهايه احنا ضمن ارض
الرباط هي حرب حقيقيه يعيشها الفلسطينيون
اينما كانوا لكن باشكال مختلفه براي ابناء
المخيم ويربطون واقعهم اليومي هنا بواقع
اهلهم هناك في غزه الاحتلال كما هو معروف
عنه كشف عن وجهه الحقيقي عن عن عن عن عن
حقده ضد المخيمات تحديدا وضد ابناء شعبنا
بشكل عام العقليه تقود الحرب على غزه
وتقتل وتدمر هي نفس العقليه التي تقتحم
المخيمات وتقتل
وتدمر رغم حجم الضرر يواصل المقاومون
الفلسطينيون تصديهم لجيش الاحتلال عبر
الاشتباك مع جنوده او استهداف الياته
بعبوات محليه الصنع بدا تاثيرها هذه المره
من خلال اصابه احدى الجرافات التي ترك جزء
منها هنا على ارض
المخيم تكررت اقتحامات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمخيمات ومدن الضفه الغربيه
وتسارعت وتيرتها منذ بدايه العام في كل
مره تخلف الاليات العسكريه وجرافات كل هذا
الدمار لكن الفلسطينيين يرون ان قوات
الاحتلال تهدف من خلال اقتحاماتها لتحطيم
ارادتهم وليس فقط مجرد جدران بيوتهم
وشوارعهم حسن مسعود ال الجزيره من مخيم
نور شمس شمال الضيفات الغربيه